[Music]
scattered across the New Mexico desert
our buildings that look like something
from another world they are home
designed to be completely self estate
generating their own electricity water
gas and food they are the links work of
an unconventional architect Mike
Reynolds who will use homes of the key
to a better future we came up with the
name hardship because houses have to
have gas lines coming in sewage lines
going out electric lines coming in and
so these buildings provide all of that
themselves these buildings address
comfortable shelter electricity water
sewage treatment garbage and food
Michael Reynolds started all this off
the oil crisis in the 70s once the
prices went up that meant everything we
had to fight this weather so this house
is basically trying to make us less
dependent on all these things
[Music]
I came to town right after architectural
school in 1969 this climate is a super
severe it's real hot in the summer and
it's real cold in the winter so it's a
perfect place to test pilot these
buildings so that you see if they can
stay warm in severe conditions and cool
in severe conditions they're mountains
of automobile tires everywhere all over
the world why don't we make a use for
tires the tires give out the foundation
of the house and north of the structural
walls the tire will not rot termites
don't eat them they are resilient for
earthquake and at the same time because
they're packed with earth insight that's
going to accumulate the heat is like a
heat battery it sucks up heat and then
it gives it back to you when the
temperature of the room drop you do feel
really nurtured inside some of these
houses because inside the living space
the temperatures of same all year-round
then we have plastic and glass bottles
we cut them in half and we put the two
bottom ends together it means that we'll
be using much less to make because we're
using this other material which
compensates at the same time it's going
to let light coming to the house you can
do combination of colors you could be
mosaic Reynolds and his team have been
sharing their designs around the world
developing curve shifts in places of
need I lay in bed sometimes awake at
night can't wait to get up the next
morning and keep doing this we're
building or drawing we're traveling
doing education I plan to keep going so
I drop but I'm already seeing that
there's people
[Music]